So, since d3's very declarative we only have to specify what we want,
in this case the exposition.
Using this knowledge about data accessers and what you already know about
d3 functions to change the properties of HTML or SVG elements
to add some more context to our chart and make a comparison, add d3 code.
To make the home country a red circle and
leave every other country a blue circle.
And also for each of the games in which the home team is involved in,
let's make them slightly more visible and increase the radius to five.
And remember, as I showed you previously,
we've augmented this data to have both a latitude and a longitude.
As well as a home column that represents the team name of the host country.